>> Tucker: AMAZING STORY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
RESEARCHERS AT THE HENRY FORD
HEALTH SYSTEM HAVE RELEASED A
NEW MAJOR STUDY OF
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
THEY FOUND THAT THE DRUGS EARLY
USE AGAINST CORONAVIRUS MAY CUT
THE DEATH RATE IN HALF.
AMAZING.
AND FOX MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR
DR. MARC SIEGEL JOINS US TONIGHT
TO DISCUSS THIS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE’VE TALKED
ABOUT MANY TIMES, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF THIS STUDY?
>> THIS IS A GROUNDBREAKING
STUDY.
I SPOKE TO THE CHIEF ACADEMIC
OFFICER AT HENRY FORD HEALTH
SYSTEMS AND SAID AS HE POINTED
OUT THAT CUTS THE DEATH RATE IN
HALF ON THE 2500 PATIENCE THEY
STUDIED AND THEY HAVE ANOTHER
STUDY COMING UP, 3,000
HEALTH CARE WORKERS TO SEE IF IT
CAN BE USED AS A PREVENTIVE.
THIS IS VERY BIG NEWS IN A BIG
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
I ALSO SPOKE TO CONGRESSMAN
MICHAEL BURGESS OF TEXAS TODAY
IT WAS A REPUBLICAN LEADER OF
THE HOUSE SUBCOMMITTEE ON HEALTH
AND HE SAID HE’S BEEN GETTING
CALLS FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
WHY ISN’T HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE
AVAILABLE FOR FRONTLINE USE AT A
TIME WHEN THE COVID OUTBREAK
PANDEMIC IS INCREASING IN TEXAS.
AND OF COURSE, THE ANSWER HE
GAVE HIS POLITICS.
AS YOU KNOW, I HAD A
CARDIOLOGIST PRESCRIBE IT TO MY
FATHER AND HE GOT DRAMATICALLY
BETTER AND GAVE IT TO MANY
PATIENCE IN MARCH AND APRIL WHO
GOT BETTER DUE TO
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE, SO WHY IS
THE EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION
BEEN REVERSED ON IT?
THE STUDY MAY CHANGE ALL OF THAT
THAT.
THERE’S A LOT OF PRESSURE ON THE
FDA TONIGHT TO REVERSE THAT, THE
EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION.
YOU CAN PRESCRIBE IT OFF LABEL
BUT MANY PHYSICIANS ACCORDING TO
CONGRESSMAN BURGESS IS THAT THIS
PRESSURE NOT TO USE IT.
SO THE FDA HAS TO STEP UP TO THE
PLATE HERE.
THIS COULD BE A VERY POTENTIAL
USABLE TREATMENT EARLY IN THE
GAME STUDYING AGAINST THE VIRUS,
VERY CHEAP, LESS THAN 50% AND
HAS BEEN AROUND FOR 50 YEARS.
WE KNOW ITS SIDE EFFECTS,
DOCTORS SHOULD BE FREE TO USE IT
AND IT SHOULD BE STUDIED
FURTHER.
IS VERY PROMISING.
>> Tucker: IT IS REMARKABLE.
YOU HATE TO SEE POLITICS DRIVE